نحن متواجدين في منطقه دير البلح
وبالتحديد في منطقه البصه حيث اغارت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه على هذه البنايه
وهذا المنزل لاحد المواطنين هنا تم نقل
عدد من الاصابات والشهداء من هذا المنزل
الذي تم استهدافه وما زال المواطنون
يحاولون اخراج مزيد من شضايا الشهداء
الذين تناثرت في كل مكان في هذه المنطقه
الغاره كانت قويه جدا من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه واحدثت دمارا بالاضافه الى
مصابين تم نقلهم عبر سيارات الاسعاف وعبر
سيارات المواطنين باتجاه مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح كما تشاهدون في هذه
الاثناء حتى سيارات الاسعاف والدفاع
المدني ما زالت متواجده هنا وتقوم باعمال
بحث و يعني وصول لوصول للوصول لمصابين او
شهداء ما زالوا في هذا المنزل الذي تم
استهدافه قبل
قليل يا شباب والله تعطيهم اعطيهم قهم
شويه اشلاق يعني اشلاق قول له اشلاق طبعا
نن في امان الله و يعني مستبعدين حكايه
قصف وداير البلح على حسب كلامهم كمان امن
مكان يعني نن هنا بيتنا وهي بيت جيراننا
تفاجانا بانه الطياره قصفتها واهل البيت
طبعا اشلاء طاروا هنا طار على بيتنا ثلاث
جسس ستات اثنتين وطفل صغير وزي ما انت
شايف دمار و خرب في كل مكان مش عارفين ايش
نحكي هي لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله وحسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل بالنسبه لي في بيت اختي
اللي انا عندها ثلاث جثث طلعت صبيين وطفله
صغيره طبعا كلهم مقطعين ومحروق وامعا
طالعه يعني تقطيع كامل زائد حروق يعني
الصاروخ مش بس كمان موت حرق وقطع وحسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل يعني اطفال صغار وستات
الشهداء هذه المنطقه الامنه هذه المنطقه
الامنه اللي كانوا يحكوا لنا كلكم تعالوا
بدير البلح وبناء على هيك ننا لجانا بناء
على قبر الحكم العسكري توجهوا لدير البلح
وتوجهنا لكن شكله فيش اي مكان امن نهائيا
نهائيا فيش مكان امن بنك الاهداف كان
اطفال وستات هي بنك
الاهداف الغاره الاسرائيليه على دير البلح
مؤخرا لم تكن الاولى حيث استانفت القوات
الاسرائيليه غاراتها الجويه خلال الساعه
الماضيه وبشكل مكثف جدا سواء في محور مخيم
النصيرات او حتى مخيم المغازي بالاضافه
الى محور مخيم البريج حيث الغارات
الاسرائيليه العنيفه ما زالت تواصل
الطائرات الحرب الاسرائيليه ارتكابها في
المحافظه الوسطى اما المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
تواصل اطلاق قذائفها باتجاه كل شيء في
المحافظه الوسطى وبشكل عشوائي وهذا الامر
ادى الى وقوع اعداد كبيره من الشهداء
والمصابين وصلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
في دير البلح اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره
دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه